why are we having this crisis at the
border
because when joe biden got elected the
first thing he did was stop construction
of the border wall
he reinstituted catch and release and he
ended the remain in mexico policy which
was this incredibly successful foreign
policy accomplishment
where the trump administration had
negotiated with mexico
that illegal immigrants from central
america would remain in mexico
while their asylum proceedings were
moving forward texas senator ted cruz
addressing the unfolding border crisis
during our last hour of america's
newsroom
our next guest says 12 people entered
his property just yesterday
nine of them were confrontational and he
fears for the safety of his family
texas rancher john sewell joins us now
we appreciate you being here set the
scene for us what's it been like
well it's been certainly a lot different
than i've ever seen it i've been here
about 25 years
so i've seen under many many
administrations i've seen lots of
trouble
but i've never seen it at this level and
i've never seen it with this quality of
people
you know there's still people coming
through that that really
are coming to to better themselves and
better their lives but i think
that the dynamics have changed of that
today it's it's not
the same group of folks that i'm used to
seeing what do you mean by that
john what's the difference well they're
more confrontational
um they have something to lose i don't
know if it's because of human smuggling
you know my problem is i'm 40 miles from
the border so
it's not like i'm sitting on the edge of
the border and all these people are
coming across the river to me
the only reason i can attribute my
problems getting bigger and bigger every
day is the value of human smuggling
and with that said i
i am right before the checkpoint on us90
so the smugglers are bringing them here
dropping them off and they're coming
through my property and
that in turn has caused lots of
heartache for us
not to mention they're tearing down our
fences they're coming to our houses at
night
i have a daughter i won't let walk on
the on the driveway
you know to to jog or exercise because
of this
without having a dog with her um you
know
we're kind of being left down here and
and the border patrols
their hands are tied i mean they're
they're working
to keep uh unaccompanied minors under
control
in a facility uh they're not out here in
the field when i meet them
they can't come because they're so
stretched out
uh you know they got they we we're
overwhelmed
i mean we've been thrown through the
wolves here as far as i'm concerned john
is that one of the reasons that you're
speaking out today and coming on
television i'm assuming that as a
rancher that you'd like to keep to
yourself
get your work done enjoy your outdoors
outdoor life and
have a good life there with your family
and you decided to come on television
today
why well i've been watching the media
just as everyone else has
and it's portraying a way different
picture than what we're having
you know we're seeing things of people
touring facilities
that look like everything's in order so
on and so forth
that's not the case you know if they
really want to see what's going on
and what what they don't want to see
then they need to come visit people like
me
that have to battle this every day in
their own backyard
the thing that they that everybody needs
to understand
these people aren't staying here they're
coming to your town
whether they're good or bad they're
coming to your town
we have too much border patrol presence
here they don't want to be here
they can't legally be here we can't
legally work them
so without a guest worker program that
works where are we going with this guys
john what's your level of confidence now
that kamala harris has been put in
charge of this
national crisis i have very little
confidence in anything that we're doing
right now
you know at least in the prior
administration we had a plan
we had something in place that was at
least controlling the issue
and they knew what was going to happen
to the individual once they were
apprehended
now we have no plan we have no direction
where are we going i don't think anybody
knows that answer do you guys
no sir not today john tremendous amount
of respect for you
thank you we'd love to keep in touch
with you please john you make some
excellent points
thanks for sharing them with our
audience and perhaps
political leaders in charge as well
thank you john i encourage anybody to
come down here and see us
i'd like to avoid texas there